in this video i'm going to be breaking
down the third episode of attack on
titan season 4.
episode 3 saw the story return to
parody's island in the form of a
flashback
where we witnessed the original attack
on the walls from all those years ago
but this time from a different
perspective this video will explain
everything that i thought was
interesting about the episode
including weiner's backstory falco's new
friend and the real reason why this
titan
did not eat bertolt before we begin be
sure to hit that sub button if you want
to see more attack on titan videos like
this and as usual let me know your
thoughts on the episode down below
okay so episode 3 was called a door of
hope and it starts off with rainer back
at his childhood home
in liberio as he lies on his bed he
begins to reminisce about the past
and we see a younger rhino struggling
through the intense training it takes
to become a warrior candidate the anime
left this part out
but in the manga rhino watched on as
bertolt annie and marcel
were selected to be candidates before he
was and that kind of emphasized the fact
that rainer was the least skilled
of all the eventual warrior candidates
however thanks to his unwavering
dedication to mali
he was selected to become a candidate in
the end and zeke tells them that
everyone except for one person
will be inheriting a titan soon as we
saw porco was certain that the one
person to miss out would be rainer
because in his mind rhino was just a
bootlegger who just listened to a lot of
mali and propaganda
this is why rhino began shouting in his
face and started ranting about the
devils on the island
earning himself a nice punch of the face
i love how after he got punched in the
face
zeke just casually told the others to
come once ryden had finished crying
like was this a regular occurrence
anyway it was after this beat down from
porco that we got a better understanding
of reiner's motivations
and this will be very relevant in the
upcoming episodes in this scene
reiner reveals that he wants to become
an honorary malayan so that his mother
and father can live together
but the underlying motivation beneath
that is that he also wants to become a
hero to the world
by eliminating the devils on the island
this is partly why later in the episode
he convinces the other warriors to
continue with the mission
even after marcel had died just before
we move on
the anime showed us this scene of a
young aaron inside the walls
and we previously saw this same moment
during season 1
in which armin showed aaron a book about
the outside world
this book is what sparked aaron's desire
to see the ocean
and free himself from the confines of
the walls and it just so happened that
on this same day
you know reiner was stating his desire
to become a hero
moving on the flashback then has a small
time skip
in which we get this suicide squad style
introduction to the new titan shifters
by this point reiner has inherited the
armored titan as as we knew he would
and he helps take down an enemy nation
alongside his fellow warriors
it was pretty awesome seeing all seven
of these titans in action at the same
time
not to mention seeing marcel's draw
titan as well for those who've missed my
previous review
marcel is the brother of porco who is
the current draws titan in the present
day
this whole sequence is basically meant
to show us why mali was so confident
in sending four children to invade
parodies island
having just crushed an enemy nation with
ease surely these kids would be able to
steal the founding titan from within the
walls
and wipe out the aldians who were living
there i mean it didn't work out but who
knows
maybe if the founding titan was someone
other than this maniac
then they you know maybe they might have
succeeded the scene then moves over to
porco threatening reiner as he just
can't believe that the bootlegger has
actually managed to nab himself
a titan shifter as porco is held back by
his brother
reiner notices that there's something
off about marcel but we'll explain that
later
these four candidates were the ones
selected for the invasion of the island
but the beast titan and the cart titan
were left at home
because you know if you send all the
titans at once then marley's going to be
very vulnerable and so that's why they
kept behind
zeke and peak during the parade reiner
spots his estranged father who is not an
aldian he is a malayan citizen
and throughout his childhood reiner was
kind of led to believe that if he became
a warrior and
by default if you're a warrior you are
also a citizen of mali
then he thought he'd be able to live
with his parents but as we can see you
know his father wanted nothing to do
with him
and basically considers reiner to be a
mistake the anime then progresses to the
invasion of the island
and as the kids make their journey
towards the walls they stop for a brief
moment and gather around the fire
it was here that we discovered why
marcel was acting strange
with the reason being that poco was
actually meant to be the armored titan
but marcel did everything in his power
to kind of like hurt his brother's
reputation
and at the same time put rhino on a
pedestal he did this to protect his
younger brother because you know there
are many
dangers associated with being a titan
with the curse of ymir being the most
obvious
marcel tearfully apologizes to rhino for
what he did
but just as reiner is processing this
information a random titan appears out
of the ground
and literally tries to eat him there and
then this titan was yamir
and prior to this moment she'd been a
pure titan for about 60 years
the reason she appeared was because the
sunlight provides energy to the pure
titans
and with the sun rising you know she had
the energy she needed
to get up and have some breakfast
luckily for rainer marcel pushed him out
of the way
saving his life in the process after
fleeing the scene
reiner is confronted by annie who wants
to abandon the mission
and return to mali annie's plan was to
return home
after finding whoever stole the draws
titan which is ymir like i said
in her words she didn't think the
mission could succeed without marcel's
leadership
rainer insisted that they persevere with
the plan to invade the walls
and he had a few different reasons
number one was that he wanted to save
his own skin and avoid being
you know avoid being eaten by the next
armored titan and reason number two
is that he kind of you know he wanted to
be a hero so that people would respect
him
and that's the part that he didn't say
out loud being a hero was his secret
motivation for continuing the plan
and after annie had beaten the crap out
of him reiner promised that he would
fill the void
that marcel left behind once they
arrived at the wall
bertolt smashed through the gate as we
know but he was then confronted by a
titan which could very easily have eaten
him
this titan used to be dinah fritz who is
the mother of zeke jaeger
and the former wife of grisha any other
titan would have eaten bertos in this
situation
but as we know this pure titan is
special not only does she have royal
blood flowing through her veins
but before she was transformed she
promised grisha that she would find him
somehow
it cannot be a coincidence that she said
these words and then immediately when
the opportunity arose
she went to grisha's house and ate his
new wife this titan only had one goal in
mind
and it was to find grisha and because
she's a titan of royal blood
i am certain that the parts that connect
all aldeans played a role
in her discovering grisha's family home
not to mention finding eren again later
in the series
if she was anyone else then bertolt
would have lost the colossal titan at
this moment
guaranteed anyway reiner and the gang
were able to sneak into the walls thanks
to all the chaos
and in this scene we can see that armin
mikusa and aaron
are among the refugees later on the
warriors meet a man from a small village
in the mountains
who tells them his story of how his
family was eaten by titans
after that man killed himself the three
of them decided to adopt his story as
their own
very disrespectful of them but you gotta
do what you gotta do
five years after they arrived on the
island annie was the main member of the
group who was actually
you know following through with the
mission based on the info they had
the king was in possession of the
founding titan and so annie began to
follow a mysterious man in a black coat
who was one of the royal government
officials this man was kenny ackerman
aka levi's favorite uncle and he started
working with the royals after his
dangerous encounter
with the previous king of the walls
after catching her by surprise
she made up some random story about how
she was looking for her long lost father
before attempting to kick him can we
just appreciate how powerful her kick
was in this moment
because i mean she knocked a brick out
of position and she's not even in her
titan form so
that's pretty impressive while annie
escaped kenny was able to get a glance
at her face
which put the entire plan in jeopardy
kenny could easily blow her cover
especially if she got close to the royal
family so for that reason
annie wanted to abandon the mission yet
again but reiner actually had a good
plan this time around
instead of abandoning the mission reina
proposed that they get the founding
titan to reveal
himself and suggested that they attack
wall rose
this plan proved to be successful
because once the colossal titans smashed
the gate and let all those titans in
the ensuing violence is what led to
aaron awakening his titan powers
the flashback ends with this moment of
eren in the cadets
and this is when he was struggling to
master the odm gear he asks reiner how
he can improve
because obviously you know if you can't
master the oem gear
then how could he get revenge on the
titans like he promised he would in this
brief moment
reiner is reminded of himself as a young
child reiner helps aaron up
and tells him that the only thing he can
do to get better and accomplish his
goals
is just to keep moving forward that line
is super important at the end of this
episode
so make sure you remember it this
flashback scene was then interspersed
with images
of rhino loading up his gun in the
present day as he prepares to pull the
trigger
and just end everything at this point in
time reiner is just tired of living
and everything he's been through has
just taken its toll on him
and he he feels like he has nothing left
to live for just as he goes to pull the
trigger
falco coincidentally bangs on the wall
in frustration
which interrupts rhino falco's
frustration stems from the fact that
he's not good enough to surpass gabby
and he realizes that something needs to
change if he's ever going to inherit the
armored titan
if not for this moment from falco rhino
would have died there and then
and the power of the armored titan would
have been passed to a newborn alien
child
somewhere in the world the bang on the
wall gave falco a second to reconsider
what he was doing
and he realized that he does still have
something to live for which is the
remaining warrior candidates
the episode ends with falco walking past
the hospital as the soldier that he
helped in the previous episode
waves towards him as they continue to
speak falco tells the soldier about his
fear that he won't be able to inherit
the armored titan
as there's another talented candidate
that everyone loves
as falco begins to feel sorry for
himself his words are virtually
identical to what aaron was saying
earlier in the episode
when he was failing to master the
maneuvering equipment the soldier is
clearly touched by what falco was saying
and begins to wonder about why a person
goes to war
as he says some people are forced to do
it by outside factors
such as the aldians that we saw on the
front line during episode 1.
on the other hand you have people who
willingly charge into this hell
like rhino when he insisted they
continue with the mission on two
separate occasions
the soldier says that people who force
themselves to go into war
are different from those who are forced
by external factors
as it's likely that the people who force
themselves see something that others
don't
whatever that motivating factor is the
man says that you'll never be able to
find it out
unless you keep moving forward and that
was the conclusion of this episode
just in case i didn't make it clear
enough in that last line the man is
quoting what rhino previously said
to him major spoiler warning ahead if
you haven't realized it by now
but the soldier that falco is talking to
is in fact aaron yeager
we'll get into the details of how and
why it's possible another time
but the last line of episode 2 made it
very obvious
that this man is who we think he is let
me know in the comments if you realize
who this was before watching this video
or seeing this title
but anyway guys that was the breakdown
for episode three
i'd appreciate if you dropped a like if
you liked it and please do share it with
anyone who you think
might enjoy watching it until the next
one peace out